Remember that in
our previous video,
we created four new variables,
HighSodium, HighFat, HighCarbs,
and HighProtein.
Now in this video, we
will try to understand
our data and the relationships
between our variables
better, using the table
and tapply functions.
To figure out how many foods
have higher sodium level
than average, we want to look
at the HighSodium variable
and count the foods
that have values 1.
We can do this using
the table function,
and give it as an input
the HighSodium vector.
Now pressing Enter, we obtain
the following information.
Most of the foods
in our data set,
and precisely 4,800 of them,
have lower sodium than average,
and we have 2090 foods
that have higher sodium
content than average.
Now let's see how
many foods have
both high sodium and high fat.
Well, to do this we can
also use the table function,
but instead of giving
it one input, now
we can give it two inputs.
So let's go back
using the Up arrow,
and now have the first
input being the HighSodium
vector and the second input
being the HighFat vector.
And we obtain the
following table.
The rows belong to the first
input, which is HighSodium,
and the columns correspond
to the second input,
which is HighFat.
So from the table
we see that we have
3,529 foods with low
sodium and low fat,
1,355 foods with low
sodium and high fat, 1,378
foods with high
sodium but low fat,
and finally 712 foods with
both high sodium and high fat.
Now, what if we want to compute
the average amount of iron
sorted by high and low protein?
Well, to do this we can
use the tapply function.
Let us have a little
refresher on how
the tapply function works.
The tapply function takes
three arguments, and groups
the first argument according
to the second argument,
and then applies argument three.
For instance, we wanted to
compute the average amount
of iron sorted by
high and low protein.
In this case, the
first argument is
whatever we are
trying to analyze,
which is the Iron vector,
and we are sorting it
according to the vector
HighProtein, which
is our second argument.
And finally we apply
the mean function
in R on the sorted Iron values.
And we should not
forget to remove
the nonavailable entries.
So what does tapply do exactly?
Suppose that we have
the following data
frame with the foods
one through six,
along with information
about their Iron levels
and their values of HighProtein
that we just added earlier.
The first step is
grouping the Iron data
according to the
values of HighProtein.
So, first group, all the
foods that have HighProtein
equal 1, and that would
be food number two
with 12.8 milligrams of
iron, food number three
with 1.44 milligrams of
iron, and food number six
with 2.29 milligrams of iron.
Then we group the remaining
foods that have protein levels
below average, and
this corresponds
to food one, food
four, and food five.
Then we compute the mean of
Iron level for each group.
In this case, the mean of the
group with high protein levels
is 5.51, and the mean of the
group with low protein levels
is 1.72.
And this is the result
of the tapply function.
Now let's go back to
R and have a hands
on practice on how to
use the tapply function.
So let's compute
the average amount
of iron sorted by
protein levels.
So we're going to type tapply,
and then the first argument
is the Iron vector which
we are trying to analyze.
And we are sorting it according
to the HighProtein vector,
so this is our second argument.
And then the mean
statistic is used,
because we're
trying to calculate
the average level of Iron.
And do not forget to remove the
non available entries by typing
na.rm=TRUE.
And here's the result.
Foods with low
protein content have
on average 2.55
milligrams of iron
and foods with high
protein content
have on average 3.2
milligrams of iron.
Now how about the maximum
level of vitamin C
in foods with high
and low carbs?
Again, we're going to use
the tapply function, so
use the Up arrow to go back
to the previous command,
but now we're trying to
analyze the VitaminC vector.
So this is our first argument,
And we are sorting it
according to high and low
carbs, so the second argument
is the vector HighCarbs.
And instead of the mean,
we're applying here
the max statistic, and
we obtain the following.
The maximum vitamin C level,
which is 2,400 milligrams
is actually present in a
food that is high in carbs.
Well, is it true that foods
that are high in carbs
have generally high
vitamin C content?
Well, to see if this
is the case, now
we're going to go back
to our tapply function,
and instead of the
max statistic we're
going to use the
summary function.
We obtain the following
two sets of information.
The first set corresponds to
the foods with low carb content,
and the second set of
information corresponds
to foods with higher carb
content than average.
Now the statistical information
that the summary function
gives us pertains to
the vitamin C levels.
This means that we have
on average 6.36 milligrams
of vitamin C in foods
with low carb content,
and on average 16.31 milligrams
of vitamin C in foods
with high carb content.
So, it does seem
like a general trend.
Foods with high carb content are
on average richer in vitamin C
compared to foods
with low carb content.
Now we reach the end of
our first recitation.
I hope this was a good exercise
to familiarize yourself better
with R, and learn some
fun facts about nutrition.
Stay healthy.